a new villain enters a picture in
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one while he has his merits who can't
help but long for the return of the bad
guy who made such a huge impact in the
previous film warning spoilers for dead
reckoning part 1 ahead in a franchise
field on secrets and high-tech surprises
that make the mission all that much more
difficult their Reckoning part 1
distinctly lagged when it came to the
shock Factor sure there were a few
twists here and there and Jaws dropped
sing Tom Cruise riding a dirt bike and
ditching at mid-flight but it lacks
something that the previous movie
Fallout had a perfect opposing Force
against Ethan Hunt Henry cavill's August
Walker elevates Fallout to some of the
highest highs of the mission impossible
franchise he's the hammer to hunt
scalpel and their final showdown on the
side of a Himalaya Mountain is an epic
one that demonstrates caval could be
just as magnetic trying to end the world
as he was trying to save it in other
roles this proves nothing I'm playing a
role just like you are Eastside Morales
Gabriel slides into the lead villain
role in dead reckoning part 1. and he
provides a different kind of threat he's
a smoother operation sir and frankly
pales in comparison to caval's hulking
but equally manipulative Mastermind the
Revelation that caval's first reloading
CIA man was the brains behind Ethan's
problems made August Walker more of a
force to be reckoned with than Gabriel
could ever be where Alice's Gabriel
gains an edge thanks to a powerful AI
called The Entity but it actually makes
him a less compelling foe as the
messenger for the entity paralysis
antagonist feels almost like the mission
impossible answer to the architect from
The Matrix he's a jargon-spouting man of
mystery that doesn't really feel like
much of an imposing figure also while
Gabriel is supposed to have a history
with hunt it doesn't really feel like it
everything has to be filled in with
flashbacks referring to characters who
have never been mentioned before that's
where Walker making a comeback would
feel so much more impactful we've seen
these two go Toe to Toe we know they can
push each other's buttons and seeing
more of that would make any future
Mission Impossible chapter with cavil
all the more enjoyable it'd be the
perfect time to have him pay a return
visit as well given his current schedule
you're not getting rid of me Daddy's
after hanging up the cave of Superman
and passing the white dwarf onto Liam
Hemsworth for The Witcher seeing him
stroke back on the scene for Mission
Impossible twice as angry and just as
unhinged would be welcome more
importantly it could cement covers as
one of the most consequential villains
in The Mission Impossible franchise it'd
be a blowfell to Ethan Hunt's Bond if
you will as the world waits for the
baited breath for a new James Bond to
hit the big screen Ethan Hunt and his
Ensemble of spies have the Espionage
action Market covered at the moment
calling upon Henry Cavill could
establish August Walker as a permanent
threat to hunt just as blowfailed as
long been for Bond much like the lunatic
with the top Specter spot Walker has
already shown his managerial skills by
handling the apostles or hiding in plain
sight if he managed to go that long
without being detected it wouldn't be
that much of a shock to see him make a
killer comeback as an even more maniacal
Force there is of course a matter of
Walker having died by falling off that
mountain in Fallout but bringing him
back from the dead wouldn't be such a
wild idea long time Tom Cruise
collaborator Christopher McQuarrie who
directed the last three entries in the
Mission Impossible franchise told The
Hollywood Reporter in 2021 I'm in the
process of the rising Mission 8 right
now this afternoon I could turn a page
and any actor from the past could come
back there is no such thing as deaths in
movies only and availability what better
way to throw hunt off balance and
setting up a rematch would all be hyped
to see the stunts and dead reckoning
part 1 are great but that have been even
better under the looming shadow of a
former foe with thunderous Fists
foreign